you
is there anybody you guys are super
excited about seeing I hope see Tom
Hanks obviously love that guy everyone
I'm hoping everyone's gonna get naked so
that's what that's what I was told in
the script so and that's something that
you know you want to see live extreme he
said this is gonna be a really big event
excited about it I'm really excited to
see Charo she's a childhood crush of
mine hopefully I get a chance to talk to
Joss Whedon he's minimis minimis amazing
um oh my gosh Vanilla Ice potentially I
mean he's here well listen we went to
see him an MC Hammer and we were kids
and he didn't show yes I feel like this
is like the culmination of 20 years of
waiting for vanilla ice to perform for
us he's right there behind and he hasn't
changed a bit heavy vanilla ice back in
the day that was it I am excited to see
everybody here people from burning love
people from halo I'm very excited I
don't know who's gonna be here so I'm a
wide open to anybody we love that
Chantelle's impossible song and a few of
our friends are actually in that
performance so we're really excited to
see it come together a lot dailygrace
Soulja Boy no no oh did I just say no to
soldier boy oh no oh my soldier boy fans
oh my gosh alison has a swim I've been
following her career for a while I'm
actually presenting her category today I
hope she wins I have nothing to do with
it but I hope she wins excited to see
other creators of web series frankly I
mean it's just a night for to celebrate
the work that we've been doing on the
web any industry that you've been a part
of for long enough it becomes almost
incestuous you work with everyone and
you become friends with everyone and
just feels almost like I get together
almost like a reunion of sorts so I'm
excited to see almost all of my old
friends and people that I've worked with
a long time ago just like a reunion for
me because I don't work with so many
folks so for me I'm just happy to see
all the hosts come out
okay one big reported to another how do
you stay so cool in this eat I just got
here that's why they give me another
five minutes I'm Mediterranean man i'll
be sweating up a storm I'm glad I put
sunblock on SPF 15 thinking maybe I
should have done SPF 25 I might be
burned tomorrow okay we're big guys
we're both sweating how do you have it
how do you how you have so much energy
oh I'm melting that's all I'm running on
cocaine fumes right now buddy who are
you wearing oh i'm wearing who am i
where i believe this is a walmart and no
it's expressed it Dolce & Gabbana and
Versace and a little bit of nordstrom
rack and this is pay less I'm very happy
to be here oh that's good me too new
media rock stars is the best of all the
websites we excited to be here and be in
like you know the online industry has
become so prevalent and like this is
such a big deal so that's kind of cool
it's just it's great to be here and have
a good time and you know it's gonna be a
fun trip it's really fun just to get all
dressed up and hang out together and
we're enjoying it excited to be here and
sees our favorite YouTube stars man I'm
just happy to see everybody I'm happy to
be here I'm honored that people
appreciate everything that's going on
here and this is what it's all about to
showcase the new avenue for success in
music man to get the name out there to
get your skills and talent so that's
what it's all about the internet oh my
there goes the internet I mean it's not
only something that we do because it's
what we do but we also just love life
looking at videos I'm performing tonight
is amazing man the Streamy Awards I
can't believe it this is so amazing and
it's clear feels good to be here man I
love you too this is amazing this
it's a platform that let my music and my
brand and my dancing and just me as a
person it gave me a whole nother
audience so YouTube is amazing everyone
here is pretty amazing and pretty good
at doing a specific thing and has their
own fan base and I throwing world and
it's just an honor to be a part of it
you know just to be included I come kind
of from a different background than a
lot of the people here on YouTube and
everybody's been some nice and inviting
I'm just excited about that you know the
fine brothers built our whole world
before I even met them they kind of
brought me in and now it feels like
family and this is just like a big
celebration of family you know we're not
the types to feel like oh yeah I really
hope we win I think that that's things
like tonight are just celebration and an
order to be a part of for the community
so I don't really mind if we win or lose
it's good for the space is good it's
good for mortal kombat but i mean we're
all friends so honestly whoever wins i'm
so excited i mean i'm just really
excited to mostly be here and just to be
with everybody doing what they really
love so it's amazing